the final meters of alexi navalny's
journey from siberia to berlin
one that the kremlin critics spent
unconscious
navalny was flown out on this plane
chartered by a berlin ngo
his supporters had feared for his life
after a suspected poison attack on the
opposition leader
navalny's wife yulia requested treatment
in germany
but the medical evacuation was only
given the green light
after a tug of war between russian and
german doctors
over whether he was fit to fly
navalny's spokeswoman kira yarmish
thanked supporters
and said the transfer abroad was a first
step in what would be a long struggle to
restore navalny's health
berlin charity hospital is no stranger
to treating kremlin critics who appear
to have been poisoned
two years ago activist piotr vasilev was
taken here after showing poisoning
symptoms
he helped secure the same treatment for
navalny
navalny has been one of president
vladimir putin's fiercest critics
the 44 year old former lawyer was barred
from challenging putin in the 2018
presidential election since then he has
campaigned on behalf of opposition
candidates in regional polls
supporters hope that german doctors will
be able to get to the bottom of what
caused navalny's sudden debilitating
illness
in a safe environment free of any
political interference
and dw reporter julia saudelli is
outside the sherate hospital while
navani
is being treated trulia greetings uh
as we just heard the charity hospital
began treating the comatose navalny
can you give us any more details at this
point
what the hospital is saying is that they
have begun
tests on navalny they are looking at
treatment options and that it will take
time for them to determine
what exactly happened to him and how to
proceed therefore
they asked for patience in receiving
more details regarding his health
condition what we heard from
the director of cinema for peace the
foundation that brought navalny to
berlin
is that his condition is stable but it
is definitely worrying he is not out of
the woods
you know it's worth noting that it
wasn't the german government that
brought navalny here but rather that ngo
that you just referenced
can you tell us a little bit more about
who they are
cinema for peace is a foundation based
in berlin
it is financed by philanthropists who
support humanitarian projects
especially filmmakers working on social
issues
they have organized this trip and they
said it has been
financed through donor private donor
money
they said the they did not want to
reveal who these donors were
and the chief of the foundation said
earlier
that he also did not want to reveal how
much the trip
came to cost he said it was however very
expensive also because organized at the
last minute
you know julia some might remember that
the charity
has a history of treating foreign
leaders and famous dissidents and we
just mentioned that in the piece of
course
is that why alexei navoni was taken
there
certainly the fame of the charity it's
being renowned as a worldwide top class
hospital was a reason for navalny to be
brought here
his family wanted the best care possible
for him but
also the fact that this similar case
from piotro vasilov who was brought here
the [ __ ] riot activist was brought here
two years ago also for a suspected
poisoning
gave the hospital a head start on
knowing how to deal with these cases and
also to give the family the certainty
they need that there will be an
independent investigation into the
causes of his illness
julia saldelli in berlin for us much
appreciated julia